hello everyone and welcome to round four
of the meltwater champions chester
finals it's vladislav artemia versus
magnus carlsen and uh we're not only
going to show one game now we're going
to show one game plus uh two parts of um
two other games so we're gonna skip game
one game one between the two of them
ended in a draw uh not a lot happened
there it was a fine game but nothing uh
out of the ordinary uh this here is game
two a position from game two where
magnus had the white pieces uh and um
well the the position is uh very very
drawish uh but uh in the game uh after
bishop to e6 artemiev offered the trade
of bishops magnus played this knight the
c7 move so he offered his bishop
and a knight to win the rook on a6 uh
will of course win for this bishop
captures knight captures b captures and
uh artemis proceeded just you know to to
win this end game so not
the greatest of exchanges for magnus so
this is what happened in game two and in
game two artemis took the lead in the
match so now magnus needs to bounce back
uh but uh in the next game uh he has the
black pieces and this is game three the
game that we're going to show uh in its
fullest so let's check it out and see
what happens there as we're also gonna
uh briefly comment on game four so uh
artemis with the white pieces opens with
e4 uh we have knight uh we have c5
magnus goes for the sicilian defense and
not knight to f3 but knight to c3 uh
trying to go for some sort of a close
sicilian and knight to c6 by magnus with
bishop to b5 and immediately challenging
this bishop with knights to d4 so here
usually people just go bishop back to c4
because you do not want to allow this
trade of bishop for a knight but uh
artemis just continues knight to f3 we
have a6 by magnus and now bishop back to
d3 and only now that the bishop has been
played
placed on such an unfavorable square
magnus retreats with the knight knight
to c6 and okay we have castles by
artemis d6 by magnus and now bishop the
c4 getting ready to strike in the center
with the d4 to open up the position uh
e6 by magnus and now d4 so striking in
the center c captures knight captures
and now knight to f6 uh and here uh
there um is a game where bishop to d2
was played uh or rather uh bishop to d2
not bishop to d2 bishop to e3 bishop to
d2 would be just weird uh but here
magnus plays uh sorry our teammate plays
knight captures on c6 and it is now as
of move tended we have a completely new
game
uh so let's see what happens we have b
captures on c6 and rook to e1 now maybe
with some ideas of pushing e5 so magnus
prevents this pushes e5 himself
but this does open up this diagonal for
artemium slight square bishop so bishop
to g5 bishop to e7 and now queen to d3
preparing to bring the other rook into
the game as well h6 asking do you want
to trade or do you want to go back of
course artemis wants to keep his bishop
here as magnus is probably castling
king's side so you want to keep the
option of playing queen to g3 and then
you're going to have a lot of pressure
on that castle king
magnus does castle king side and now h3
we have a5 and now bishop back to b3 so
what do you do here bishop to a6 doesn't
really do all that much for black you're
just gonna shift the queen over to g3
like we already mentioned so queen to c7
and now rook a to d1 we have bishop to
e6 by magnus countering the light square
bishop on b3 and now knight the a4 at
some point we're probably gonna
eliminate this pawn or somehow maybe
capture here and then maybe win the c5
square for our knight but it's also just
very useful there guarding the b6 and c5
squares maybe the bishop can uh help out
in the future so all in all i will place
knight but uh most of all we want to
trade this bishop
uh for our for
the bishop on e6 and then we're gonna
push some pawns here basically so here
magnus says all right you allow me to
push d5 and of course that's basically
the sicilian dream i will do that so d5
by magnus and now
a very special moment where uh artemis
has to choose the
between capturing and d5 and playing g3
right away uh queen to g3 and the thing
is if you capture on d5 right away it
makes sense for example c captures and
queen to g3 you're now threatening
bishop captures on h6
as the g pawn is pinned but also you're
just threatening to win a pawn here
but artemis had a different idea he
played queen to g3 and he left this pawn
uh here to be captured by the by the
knight and this is exactly what magnus
goes for
knights the h5 somewhat safer play but
magnus goes for for the kill knight
captures on e4 artemiev grabs the
exchange with rook captures on e4 we
have d captures on e4 and now of course
bishop captures an h6 artemia uh
threatens checkmate so bishop to f6 we
have to defend g7 and now bishop
captures an e6 we have f captures on e6
now tripling carlson's pawns here and
knight to c5 now uh threatening just
knight captures here to win uh back the
exchange but also uh before that threat
there is the threat of rook to d7 and
that's just game the queen will have to
move and we're gonna capture here uh
checkmating the the the black king the
g7 pawn would be attacked three times so
rook a to d8 magnus cannot allow this
and now rook to e1
artemy if not uh interested in trading
uh uh rooks we have queen to f7 now
guarding the e6 square
and knight captures on e4 now uh so what
you play here well you have to add more
defenders to the g7 pawn uh but magnus
decides to go just bishop back to e7 not
allowing this attention to remain here
but also just opening up this f file for
the queen and rook so now if uh
the df2 pawn will not be sufficiently
protected we can always capture that uh
but this allows artemis uh the
the opportunity to uh just lift the rook
to e3 and now magnus has to play a move
but only one move is playable here for
black but it's maybe not so clear as
magnus fails to play it uh and that move
is king to h8 you have to play king to
h8 magnus played king to h7
which kind of makes more sense but
it loses the game for him so here bishop
to g5 was played by artemis with the
simple thread of just queen to h4 check
picking up the bishop on e7 so magnus
retreated with king the g8 but now yeah
feel free to pause the video and win
this game for artemis while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is rook
to f3 and that's why the king does not
belong here you had to move the king in
the corner so you can bring the queen
over to g7 but now there really isn't
all that much you can do uh this was not
played in the game i'm just showing you
what would happen the queen would have
to move and now we repeat bishop to h6
we threaten checkmate now the king queen
cannot remain on f7 we're just going to
capture the queen so rook to f7 has to
help out with the defense now queen to
g6 going after queen captures and e6
rook to g3 is coming so queen to f8
adding another defender here and now
rook the g3 and now uh if you look at
the position there's uh really not an
active move that black can play here he
can just wait and see what will happen
the e6 pawn will fall and all of these
pawns are really weak black has no no
counter play here if you try something
like rook d4 to put pressure on the
knight we can just play bishop to e3
chase away the rook after rook moves c3
and now there really isn't anything more
uh you can play here uh if you try
giving back the exchange we're just
gonna capture it but we're still up upon
and black's pawn structure is completely
messed up this would be an easy win for
white however artemis was very low on
the clock and he did not see this he
played bishop to h6 he repeated the
position and magnus very happily
repeated king to h7 bishop to g5 king to
g8 and bishop to h6 and he was in this
position on move 30 that they agreed to
a draw
uh which means that game one ended in a
rod in game two ended by artemis winning
the game
the one that we already uh
mentioned where magnus just sacrificed
uh uh two pieces for the rook and then
it just didn't work out here artemev
also had a win but uh he didn't find it
due to being very low on the clock and
now comes the game four that we're just
going to show this position uh magnus
played a played a fine game uh he he
attacked he had a winning position then
entertainment had a winning position
then magnus and this is basically the
end position uh where magnus is down a
whole rook magnus has the white pieces
here uh and he can't continue attacking
the black king there simply aren't um uh
any
any any useful checks here and magnus
was checking the blacking he was just
delivering checks all over the place and
now he was hoping that artemia free
moves uh you know pre-moving is that
when you play a move uh before your
opponent play the move so you don't
spend any time on the clock when you're
playing online uh magnus
played queen captures on c5 with check
and he was hoping that artemis has
already pre-moved uh something like king
to h4 or king to h6 so he can just win
his queen uh but artemis did not
pre-move he just captured carlson's
queen and he was again in this position
on move 51 in game four that magnus
carlsen resigned the game so in the
match against vladislav artemyev two
wins for a tamiya and two draws not not
a good one for magnus so
big uh a big success for um for chuck
norris here uh so yeah that's the game
or rather those are the games i hope you
guys enjoyed them uh i would like to
thank john sved josh comer david kimura
and myself for making great videos and
vladolaro for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this fine
event checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day